it's been really difficult as
you know our whole industry just came to
a stop
uh mid-march last year um
once people can't gather there can't be
any concerts
uh or large events um
we're all or most of the people in the
industry are self-employed
so there's been no help from anybody uh
until the charity came along and there
and did its bit um you know
we we don't have any fear though we
don't have anybody
uh to uh to pay us if we don't work we
don't earn
if we don't earn we don't eat uh and rob
unlike the artists who sort of could
move their um skill
online roadie simply can't do that
can they absolutely not i mean it's such
a common problem i'm afraid at the
moment there's so many people slipping
through the gaps
they can't work they're not earning
they're not able to access the funding
that's available
so um it's amazing that we've been able
to get so many people to come together
to raise some money to help them out
and rick am i right and saying that
you've had to to sell your own home
to to make ends meet yeah
yes um we've had to downgrade uh
obviously everybody put some money away
for a rainy day but nobody was really
expecting a monsoon
you know um so yeah we've uh
we need you need to earn money you know
you need to find money from somewhere
there there doesn't seem to be any light
at the end of the tunnel
so uh yeah um it had to be done
yeah no sorry to hear that rob tell us
about the i love live
campaign and what the idea behind it is
it's a very simple idea it's absolutely
critical to the music industry as you've
heard
so people can come together on
crowdfunder we've reached out to the
world's biggest bands and artists and
they've given up some amazing
prizes so for a small donation which
goes straight through to the
stagehand charity every donation gets
the opportunity to win one of these
amazing prizes
and then it goes through and it helps
people like rick and hundreds more
just to keep keep going you know and and
keep them earning which is uh fantastic
so so it's a prize draw and various
artists are putting up
items for um sort of auction
um you've had lots of support from the
artists haven't you
unbelievable absolutely unbelievable so
you mentioned queen and iron maiden
yes the foo fighters mumford and sons
and uh the spice girls my favorite we've
um
we've got the sofa from the spice girls
world tour the
the union jack sofa which everyone will
know which is my favorite so uh
there's plenty of things everyone should
go and have a look at what amazing
things that they've managed to put up
you know
stuff that you just can't get your hands
on normally wow rick i saw you smiling
there
um it's obvious that that you miss um
not only the income but but the
lifestyle just describe for us
exactly what it's meant being away from
that whole life
it's been uh it's been quite surreal
really spending so much time at home
i i'm married with with children and
it's been although it's been great to be
spending time with them
uh they're used to me being away i'm
used to uh
getting aeroplanes around the world and
uh and traveling to different countries
and obviously the money is the uh the
main thing we do we all do this as a
living
so hope to uh to you know to earn money
rob how do you see that the future i
know it's very difficult to um
look ahead but do you see that the live
music events industry
returning as it previously was or how
how might it be different in the future
to survive
i i don't think it will be the same i
mean we've got all sorts of problems to
try and get
you know everything back on track um
obviously a lot of the
the music events and lots of the other
things that we're supporting are all
going digital so
i don't think it's going to be very soon
before we're all you know
up against each other bouncing around at
a concert um so
i think we've got a real challenge on
our hands to try and get everything back
back in but one of the things that's
really important is that the sort of
mental health of the country
needs things like music it needs
entertainment we need to be doing fun
things and
anything we can do to try and help that
is great so if we can keep the whole
thing going
until we get to that moment where we can
see the light at the end of the tunnel
and that's fantastic
uh and rick rob they're talking about
the mental health of the country uh but
also the
mental health of of roadies really
how have you been coping in that respect
um trying to keep out keep myself busy i
know a lot of
my friends and brothers and sisters at
the road have been doing the same
people have been looking for alternative
work
myself i found it very very difficult i
spent 40 years in the music industry
i don't really have uh any
qualifications for anybody anything else
really
um and i'm getting a little bit too old
to be
stuck in shelves in the supermarket
although i'd be happy to do that if
anybody would employ me to do it
um but we're all you know
i'm getting on uh all i do really is
travel the world with
rock and roll bands putting on rock and
roll shows and hopefully bringing
enjoyment to people yeah that's what i
want to get back
doing yeah no it's not it's not a bad
life mixing uh with some of the great
rock and roll red
we've heard you've had a wonderful life
as a roadie haven't you
i have i've worked with some great bands
or some good fantastic people
over the years from uh coldplay
iron maiden judas priest uh george
michael
spice girls i did top of the pops i've
done the brit awards the mtv
awards um we did the opening of the
channel tunnel
um greenwich millennium uh
net aid at wembley nelson mandela
that's enough name josh that's enough
name-dropping
you've impressed me you've impressed me
um so rob how much are you hoping to
to raise and how can people uh bid for
some of these wonderful items
well we've raised over 600 000 pounds
already which is fantastic as but
there's a long long way to go
um if people want to help out it's just
a small donation five pounds gets you
into the price draws they can go to
crowdfunder.com and look for i love live
and and i'm sure they'll find some
amazing things so they're making a great
gesture and there's a chance to win
something really fabulous from their
favorite bands and artists
brilliant hope you raised lots of money
rick and rob thank you both for speaking
to us this morning thank you